a 12-year-old is dead and a 16-year-old  is in the hospital tonight after a  triple homicide in henderson tuesday  now it happened at an apartment complex  near stephanie in wigwam  police responded to a call and found two  women dead at the scene  a year old was hurt nearby and a 38 year  old suspect was found armed inside of a  car with a 12 year old boy being held  hostage  that suspect shot the boy and police  shot the suspect and both of them died  at the scene  cbs in utah is identifying one woman  killed as diana  howetheme and the 12 year old as her son  joseph  her teenage daughter yasmine is said to  be in critical condition  no officers were hurt police believe the  suspect lived in the apartment  just above the victims